it was like the female side of his
personality that's what they're saying
they're saying that it is it it's it's
really Thor that like Thor is a Essence
and it imbued itself into this female
okay fine then be be okay fine if Thor
is a hammer basically and anybody up the
hmer all right that's that's fine the
problem that I have well they have been
hinting that Miller has a mind of its
own I figured they pretty much said that
when uh when whatever her name was the
wife of Odin was like like the Hammer's
like grown beond your control yeah Freya
was like the Hammer's beyond your
control now or whatever I mean that's
that's fun if if the Marvel wants to
turn the hammer into the One Ring then
that's okay go ahead all right but my
issue is is this they really should have
picked a better story to introduce the
female version of Thor like the main
villain of issue number one were the
frost Giants busting out of the earth
classic Thor villain everyone knows
about the frost everybody knows but
that's the problem is I'm no one knows
anything else what you gonna do fight
Loki like you can't do I mean a a versus
a female Loki I'd be down with
that EV you can't just start with that
because then where you go where do you
go from there like they gotta build to
that that's the problem with the Man of
Steel movie they they started with the
big bang now what do they do now now we
have to have Batman and Superman fight
because we can't do anything else we
already blew up with trou
I mean I'm not worried about the future
of of the female version of Thor because
or I guess for for Thor because I mean
she's going to be able to fight
alongside the Avengers and so on and so
forth and she's going to be able to play
the same role that Thor always played
you know I mean I don't I don't see that
being a problem and what Marvel might do
is with their Summer Event they might
just go back and just say okay fine Thor
Odin son's just going to be that way
forever and like this is the new Thor
for forever more I don't know they're
not gonna do that it's gonna be reset by
Thor 3 Avengers 2 of Thor 3 she's she'll
be back they implied this is going to go
on for a while because we've seen a few
clips into the future and he's still got
the axe and you know he's not Thor she's
not either like we don't see her very
often and like they say that that
they're not going to reveal who she is
until she's done which means that
they're she is eventually going to stop
being Thor and get it back it's just
it's going to revert back to the status
quo whenever the movie comes around uh
that way people aren't confused as to
why there's a lady Thor now what might
happen is that she might get her own
Hammer allaw bet Ray Bill and then just
be another awesome character but Thor is
obviously come back he's going to be
like Piccolo Crow an arm
again oh my God
break but uh ordinarily I don't like to
judge a series by you just one issue I
usually like I don't even like to judge
it by its first trade I like to at least
give it a little bit so it really you
know gets its story going my only
exception to that was the newest
incarnation of Batgirl because I just
did not like I was really excited about
her her newest adaptation but it just
did not when I read it it it kind of
just felt like a bit of pandering they
just kind of they overdid the the dating
app and technology and they really
overdid her uh her photographic memory
and I just didn't enjoy the problem I
have with the new Batgirl just for a
quick Sidetrack the new Batgirl is like
they they wanted to take a prominent
female character in the DC Universe in
Batgirl but Batgirl is like 28 to 30
like she's older than the entire cast
and they've they've kept her that age
but they just pretty much brought her
appearance down to 16 put her in the top
that will kind of hide any adult em
assets and now her priority is like you
said apps and phones and her roommates
and like she was going in a direction of
being on her own getting her own
relationships building up a whole and
now we just reverted her like that's
what I don't like that's that's my issue
with freaking with with the new 52 in
general was their like just refusal to
if you're going to reboot everything
reboot everything and make Barbara
Gordon like 17 but like don't make her
35 and depressingly S like like cuz can
you IM imagine like a 32-year-old like
being like hey what up like I'm whipping
up apps and I'm moving in with like
girls half my age and like I'll go back
to college like it's just like you're
like what the no it's fine it's fine if
you're in that group like everyone
around you is 30 and you're all like
yeah this is a great idea but when
you're hanging out with not what this is
no it's like she's 32 or so hanging out
with the 18year olds like oh hey guys
what's
going I wanted it to be good yeah I I
was really excited about it because I
love female protagonists and I think
that there definitely need to be more
and more they're done properly and I
just think this was not done properly I
do think the art I think was just
pandering I love the art for that issue
though or for that it's really it's
really
goodlooking was more Indie kind of like
Scott Pilgrim that's what I'm saying
like I really like the art and I gotta
say like I hate to say it because like
it it felt like pandering the the
redesign it's growing on me like I think
it's actually kind of a cool redesign I
like the costume and everything I just
don't like her character no
everything about the Aesthetics I love I
don't like I'd be okay with the
character if she was deaged if they like
took away the other thing was wouldn't
it be cool if they took away like this
is Blasphemous I'm sure but like
wouldn't it be cool if they undid
killing joke because number one Killing
Joke was supposed to be out of
continuity anyway number two um it still
exists and you've undone everything else
so you might as well undo Killing Joke
and number three it hasn't it's not like
you've erased it from the cultural
Consciousness so like the looming threat
of the kill joke taking place again
could all like is always ever present in
the series so like you could always be
worried that like oh my God like things
are going so well for Barbara The Joker
could kick in the door any minute and
paralyze her like true because who could
who could resist the urge nobody clearly
could resist the urge to retell the
killing joke but for some reason they
were like no let's keep that but let's
throw out all these let's throw out year
one but let's re but let's keep the
Killing Joke it's really weird you know
you know what Honestly though the
easiest thing they could have done is
she got hit with a daging it's a comic
book she could got hit with a daging
problem solved now she's young again
well they did that with a not like a
dhing right but like you could always
just say like well the Earth's got
merged and she merged with a younger
version of herself and like multiversity
is happening but anyway okay so I think
we've gone on enough on back wait this
lady here I like DC more than Marvel
Sumi here's the thing that you have like
when when when you're introducing a new
character in a Marvel Comics when you're
introducing a new story the first story
has to snatch people up and drag them in
like it has to get their attention right
off off the bat like that's why like
Iron Man number 94 or uh X-Men number 94
was such a big deal because you
immediately went to the story with all
these cool new X-Men and it was it was
awesome but the issue here is that with
Thor number one I just like I was
reading through it and it was it was
like all right this is this isn't decent
all I really cared about is like what's
the deal like one we're gonna find out
what Nick Fury said to Thor and two
who's going to pick up Thor's hammer
that was my only real interest and so I
more or less just skipped to the end of
the comic and then like supposedly like
a female you know some woman picks up
the cam of Thor and wields it and I was
like okay well that sucks no resolutions
on this issue no I mean I I agree with
you that number ones need to be the
catchy they snap they got to pull you
into the comics but just like everything
else we're kind of going away from that
and comic books movies I mean used to be
back in the day if a movie had to catch
you in the first 20 minutes now we have
movies where the entire 3-hour movie is
setting up the second movie yeah sucks I
mean
hey
exactly Hunger Games to no yeah that's
that's that's the day and age we're
dealing with and I have a feeling comic
books are going in that same transition
like female Thor a great first issue
should have I mean as as a been second
issue would have been a good first issue
yes exactly second issue would have been
a great first issue or even first issue
resolve all your loose plot threads and
give her a legitimate start yes be like
here she is here's what Nick Fury said
to Thor forget about that it's over go
forward yeah yeah yeah all that should
have been done in the first issue and
then from there you focus on the female
like you f focus on the poor that would
have been I I would have read that would
have been like this is an awesome comic
exactly I think understand your problem
Rob um because like a usual thing that I
hear like uh writers talk about is that
uh whenever you're writing a book it's
that is the story you're telling the
most interesting part of your
character's life no why the hell are you
writing about it get to the interesting
part yeah exactly it would have been
great because the second issue was the
interesting part like a lot of the first
issue was just filler that could have
all been resolved in the final issue of
the Thor God of Thunder book the one
before it just done all that as the last
issue have a cliffhanger and go oh by
the way here's this awesome first issue
that they could have just literally just
moved the numbers down by one and it
would have been not even that the last
issue with Thor was garbage it was all
looking into the future showing that oh
Thor is Gonna Keep the axe for a while
here's Thor's daughters and he's the
Odin son you know and he's now the Odin
and he still has the a that means it's
going to last for a while that's that's
all the last issue with Thor was that
that's all that was yeah or at least
until May when they change it well it's
I I don't think they're going to revert
it to may I think that's too soon I can
see 4 three the worlds are colliding
everything's GNA change oh Secret Wars
made okay everything is changing it's
not going to be immediate I don't I
don't think it's going to suddenly be
like bam I mean this no it better be
because you can't drag this crap out
Secret Wars and incursions are you are
you are you serious like when they
started axis if you hadn't read like The
Magneto tians you just pick up in the
middle of axis and you have no know
that's stupid so they Marvel does that I
know they do that's stupid that's bad
that's s I'm gonna get burst your bubble
here because I just did like three days
of research about the incursions to
figure out the best way to tell that
story and that that story went literally
literally it's two freaking years to get
to the Goddamn point cuz they were a
monthly book it took two it it was it it
took pauses for infinity and original
sin it just it was like oh oh yeah we're
going to blow up worlds but hold on hold
on Thanos is here let's go do that let's
go take care of Thanos oh no Thanos is
here he doesn't do anything you guys all
stopped that's that's you man yeah
you're the one not moving you have a
very funny face sorry sorry that that
was all you guys were all like ah the
stream but here's the problem with it
the way it ends it literally ends going
into the it was eight months to L Till
die right cuz the way the incursions end
spoilers The New Avengers are dicks so
yeah they're monsters murder people
that's the that's the way it ends and it
goes into the next event and if you look
at the Timeline that timeline is going
to end right at the secret Wars guess
what Ro it's going to stretch that one
out for the six freaking month I quit
New Avengers because clearly nothing
like new Avengers was go was really
really awesome especially with um the
original artist who I can't remember I
was really enjoying it um he just he
draws velvet um anyway but in my in any
case I was reading New Avengers I'm like
this is really cool and then they were
like and we don't know when it's going
to end and I'm
like and they had like all these moral
conundrums they kept like destroying
Earths and I'm like and then Doctor
Strange is like I'm gon to sell all my
soul he he does this thing and then we
don't see that happen for another two
issues and I'm like we're going to drag
this out as long as we possible can can
well that's what's gonna happen by the
time we get to the end of Secret Wars
which is probably finally going to be
the conclusion to this incursions crap
yeah it's literally going to be a three
to foure storyline yeah ridiculous no
not for me like it'll be a straight
paperback I review on back
issues but it's going to be a three-year
story arc that that other story ARS took
place during and you're right they
definitely were taking some filler
issues to stretch long enough because
there's about four issues where it's not
even about the new Avengers they're
watching through a viewfinder other
planets die that that is when I no when
when the book opened with like alternate
version of them and you thought it was
them and then you found out and I'm like
oh no oh no we're not doing this I'm not
not coming along for this ride um that
said yeah the infinity tians were crap I
really loved the infinity core like that
core story except for the last like
issue but you know well all right uh
Steve EP is the guy that you're thinking
of SLE but yeah it's Steve epting he's
so good he he really is like his his
velvet art is pretty pretty fantastic he
also did Captain America with uh with
Brew Baker and it was so good looking
yeah that I think that's one of the
reasons why Brew Baker was like like I'm
going to do velvet like please please me
stay with me like please don't leave um
yeah now here here's all right here's
what I think all right this whole 2015
Summer Event there's no way Marvel's
gonna go through all this advertisement
and then just be like Secret Wars did we
just lose Drake we did I'm gonna add him
back I'm gonna see what happens did we
scare him he's like oh my God threeyear
story AR come
done well I guess Drake just bailed out
no no no I I
it was having an issue so I I I I booted
him oh I booted him you KCK Drake out
well it was being look he was he went
away new guy trying to add him back yeah
find a new guy sorry
everybody but um no here here's here was
here's what I think Marv was goingon to
do there's no way that Marvel's gonna go
through all this advertisement for this
2015 Summer Event and then turn around
and just be like Secret Wars issue
number one bam done and done tieing oh
no I me it's going to be this big drawn
well yeah it's and it's going to be
they're going to constantly reflect and
look back to the incursions and infinity
and original sin and all this crap that
happened before it they're going to
constantly tie to that but at the same
time they're going to try to make it a
good jumping off point you know they're
going to try all that crap yeah now
here's my question for you infinity tied
in with the new Avengers and the
incursions and what's probably going to
be secret Wars y um the uh original sin
tied into it axis seems to be gone solo
like is that it doesn't seem
there some tie-in with axis but like so
which which for the record real quick I
I am interrupting you leads us to our
second topic the current discussion
about axis seg for the win um that was
an excellent segue good sir yeah well
done textbook here's here's the thing
about about axis axis to me started off
awesome like Magneto is like we're going
to go what the Red Skull is doing
because supposedly he has camps and he
shows up there he's like oh my God he's
holding mutants and everybody's like no
Magneto don't kill him and he's like you
know what done and it kills him so
that's it and then mag which is so
Magneto I love it it's yeah that's
that's perfect Magneto I'm not goingon
to listen to anybody I'm just going to
go ahead and do what I want to do even
if it means that like really bad stuff
happens in the process yeah but um from
there we pick up with with Red Skull and
like red on and that was that was really
really cool but here's a problem that I
think Marvel that Marvel was having
Marvel was looking for a way to take all
these characters and tie them into the
2015 Summer Event what in the world is
Drake doing man oh St keep trying to re
him that's what's going on oh okay well
there's nothing wrong with that I'm just
trying to get it back on um but anyway
Marvel is is okay so one of the guys
asked what exactly is Axis okay so
Marvel is looking for a way to talk why
don't you explain that Marvel explain
yeah I like that it's not over we don't
know at this moment right now the way
axess is played out there's basically
like Magneto went to uh to U Red Skulls
camp where he was like holding mutants
like he killed Red Skull because of it
Red Skull REM manifested his red
Onslaught I think after like taking like
taking over the essence or I guess
incorporating the essence of Charles
Xavier and oh he took his brain and he
put it into his head yeah and then you
bra that's when I uncanny Avengers I
believe that was issue one I picked up
uncanny Avengers and red skull's like I
have the brain of Charles Xavier I'm
like he's dead that no you can't do that
like that's not anything not how the
brain is dead like that's how we
determine death that no you can't just
take a brain and sever it from the no
that does not I doesn't work but um but
anyway so as a result of that you uh you
have Magneto
who what's up man you're back I died I'm
doing a brief rundown on on
a start okay cool nothing I can actually
contribute to okay okay um so anyway so
at this point we have a Magneto who's uh
who's at Red skull's Camp Red Skull he
kills Red Skull Red Skull REM manifest
his red on Onslaught all right that's
where access number one picks up and my
phone is busing that's where ACC number
number one picks up from all right so
you basically have like all these
superheroes fighting Red Skull all right
red red is that a thing yeah red
Onslaught basically like and we'll we'll
get to that here in a second red
Onslaught basically like lays waste to
all the superheroes like all the ones
that are there like it's just no contest
and Quinton choir is doing his best
which I don't know Quinton choir like
Quinton choir is doing his best to like
hold off Onslaught really like unle
leashing all of his psychic energy which
eventually that fails and then like the
adaman Sentinels that apparently Tony
Stark made for Red Skull or made for
somebody at some point in time show up
and so you have like like basically
everybody getting attacked from all
fronts eventually red Onslaught is
destroyed but the problem is that this
the unleashing of psychic energy
combined with like uh Scarlet Witch and
Doctor Strange's actions have led to
like the motivations of everybody in the
Marvel Community just like switching so
good are bad guys bad guys are good guys
yeah it's forever evil but which is when
I was like this is the stupidest story
I've ever read in my life so
dumb actually I'm starting to agree with
until that point no no I'm agreeing with
you because because it's they're
promoting this is the big thing it's
crossing over multiple issues and stuff
like that but it doesn't line up with
everything that's been going on in the
Marvel Universe up till now like like
literally original sin ended with we're
going to hunt the Illuminati Iron Man's
a bad guy Captain America's do and now
we're like oh but no but before that or
or we're just going to ignore that Iron
Man lost again yeah and now you have now
you have Superior Iron Man where Iron
Man's back to like being a dick now that
book is cool and yeah he is a dick he's
like and uh PA Stewart pointed out to me
earlier hey he's back
um uh PA Stewart pointed out to me that
like it's kind of like a return to Tony
Stark like being a like weapons dealing
drunken douchebag
like classic Tony Stark which I think is
really cool well it is but where does
this T like like okay it's it's almost
like we were watching a TV show we got
to season six of this massive story arc
where now everyone's against everyone
and they decided that on no you know
what it's almost like we watched four
episodes of a TV show and then you got
to season five and the TV show decided
to change everything around almost like
lost uh or basically season
five what are you doing say anything
about lost use a different analogy
I'm halfway through season five don't
say nothing oh no okay I'm going with
the beginning of season five so you
already know the flip where the whole
thing just is like wait all my answers
are not going to get answered so we've
literally gone like three years of comic
story lines Infinity original sin uh the
incursions entire plotline Captain
America getting sentenced at the future
and coming back all of this crap
happening and then out of the blue like
and now we're going to do axis and it
doesn't tie any of that crap that's
what's kind of I mean there's there's
elements of axis that I like I like
apocalypse's back all right I think it's
kind silly that he's allying himself
with like the X-Men like it's just more
X-Men being like isolationist douche
nozzles who are like well no one will
understand us yeah pretty much it's like
like hipster or like a FYI X-Men you're
the ones who were saying that yeah oh
Drake's back sky is being a a giant butt
I have no idea what's going on I've
never had this problem well let us uh
let us start the stopwatch again and
countdown see exactly so what it is it
like uh the how long has Drake not uh
been disconnected the like how long has
it been CC has ripped off somebody's arm
yeah yeah the clock recount like it
restarts when so okay let me ask you
this because you're the one you're the
guy that you've been reading axis right
no all right never
mind like uh that was gonna spin out we
could we could we could drop the axis
conversation or we could wrap up the
conversation and segue into something
that Drake has read which is superior
Iron Man the big thing is that um I like
I I am a DC Comics Fanboy because it's
mainly just because of how I like how DC
handles their characters whereas uh DC
kind of views their characters as you
know more pop culture icons which is why
Spider-Man kind of would fit better in
DC but that's a different story for a
different time I don't know about that
man boo his out that man that's a big
allegation that'll you killed but I'm
trying to get into Marvel more and more
which is why I'm watching more of Rob's
videos he gave me a big old list and why
why all these new jumping on points are
a huge thing for me which is why I'm so
into sphere arm which is why I'm So Into
lady Thor because it actually helps
newcomers read Comics I want to give
Marvel my money but I don't know how
well here's here's a problem that that
Marvel has now Marvel used to be really
really really good about that Marvel
used to be super good about saying all
right here's like the event like this is
the one event that we're doing now now
way back in like the 80s when Luis
Simonson was like let's do ex tile
Crossovers and Claremont was like that's
stupid and she's like we're doing it
Marvel says we're doing it and clar mon
says all right fine whatever like even
then was organized like it made
sense over the place really yeah
somewhere along the line Marvel said
well you guys have the X-Men titles and
you guys have the Avengers titles and
you guys have the Illuminati titles and
you guys have Excalibur titles whatever
the thing you guys you know and and they
just said like do your own thing and
then somewhere along the line we'll just
cross them all over and so now you have
like all these interrelated titles and
you have no idea what's going on and
then there's some stuff happening here
and some stuff happening there and then
and then all of a sudden at the end it's
just like crossover you know and then
just maybe kind of makes sense well and
the Crossovers themselves weren't a
events and B like necessary like they
like you didn't need to read it in order
to know where Marvel was going to be
this year uh and also like between like
late 80s and like the 2000s like no one
gave a [__] about what the The Avengers
were doing yeah like that's why Cersei
and thunder strike and uh like Hawkeye
were main Avengers and like yeah you
know like random people who you're like
who's that like why is Firestar an
Avenger like well that that's the day
and age when superhero teams in general
because even the Justice League was
garbage oh the Justice League I mean
that was like you're not talking about
the justly classified days CU I liked
those I'm talking about like Booster
Gold and fire I know I know saying that
and and while I know you like them Drake
they probably shouldn't be aister
Justice League cast they're no they're
pretty like they they have their place
and that like that that era with uh crap
who drew the you know the the the team
with like Guy Gardner and Fire and Ice
and Batman was kind of like their
liaison the problem with back in that
day and age was the teams are used as an
excuse or he left he was like I was so
insense oh my God Drake the the the
teams at that day and age were all used
as dumping grounds for Heroes That
Couldn't that wouldn't pan out or hold
no they can't sell their own books they
would just put them on a team and and a
lot of times like Marvel Marvel did
stuff in a really cool way like Gambit
Gambit's a really cool example and guys
in the chat we we'll get to this when we
talk about um Gambit later on but what
Marvel did with Gambit oh what's going
on Welcome
Back I like how we just hearing the end
of that conversation I pretty much just
gathered how the entire conversation
wents like all these characters are
shitty and can't hold their own Comics
so that's why they threw them on a team
so I didn't really miss anything no it's
basically yeah that's basically Benny
should just read all of what I just sent
him in the chat it's uh like in on
Benny's chat I just said [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__] [__] every time that I'm
dropping out cuz I he's middle me too
I'm not getting those but Drake I did
want to let you know today we're doing a
podcast so the more you stay connected
it actually would us and allow us to do
better so Rob Rob not knows how
bad oh man the struggle is
real oh God man so perfectly pull a
pillar of professionalism and uh
togetherness yep like we know how to run
a podcast guys yeah I do have I will say
this I'm I'm now starting to see a like
call Quality red bars on my uh yeah
that's cuz Drake probably has the lowest
connection okay I wasn't sure if it was
me and I can't handle four people that
just mean that just means that somebody
has a really crappy connection okay
um private chat by the way H you have
what I'm laughing at him in another chat
like
LOLOLOL okay um but what Marvel did with
Gambit is is you had like the mutant
Massacre event and then Gambit came
along and so it was like okay you've got
like Gambit and so on and so forth and
then everybody's like Gambit get out of
here and everybody's like why are we
kicking Gambit out it's because he was
leading the mutant warlock
Massacre and like and that was that was
the big deal with him so it was a great
way for Marvel to introduce a new
character and then to say like he's got
a darker side by tying him into like a
really bad event that happened in the
history of of the EXC crossover titles
that was something that Marvel was
really really good at now they're not
good at that well they're they're so
concerned with like putting them in
charge of like I guess like maybe it's
the pro maybe the problem is that
they're just the universe is too
cohesive like there's just too much
crossover
yeah really afraid of just bridging them
together which is funny because people
keep complaining that like the X-Men
have always been kind of on the
periphery and I'm like what are you
talking about like [__] like House of
M is the bridging of those universes
it's an Avengers event that destroyed
the mutant population I feel like that's
a major crossover it it is but see
here's here's my issue when it comes to
the like I like the X-Men kind of being
out in left field and doing their own
thing I mean all honesty I always felt
like the X-Men deserved more attention
than than the Avengers did in the 90s
they got it in the ' 80s and '90s more
attention than the Avengers did but then
like the X title started dropping off
because Claremont left so um the point
came when like all the focus started
being on the Avengers but the issue that
I have here is I like the X-Men being
out in left field and they're doing
their own thing and they're dealing with
like Humanity the problem that I think
Marvel had is like with Civil War for
example like the Xmen were just not part
of Civil War they were like well like
we're dealing with decimation there's
only like 200 of us and we can't spare
any lives so you guys you guys are on
your own on that one that was a huge
mistake by Marvel well the problem is
with with it is I mean this has been
this has gone back for a while is the
X-Men floated pretty much all of Marvel
throughout the 90s like that that's
that's all anyone cared about Y and then
then Marvel was going bankrupt they sold
the rights to X-Men off so they couldn't
do much else with the X-Men at the same
time all the best writers and artists
left the X-Men leaving them in a bind
and so once they got the initial buyout
or investor I forget how they got out of
the initial bankruptcy Jam yeah they
started building up the characters they
did have rights to which was the
Avengers and then all throughout the
year you know 20 to 2010 or whatever we
had to deal with the X-Men getting a bad
rap because Fox kept putting out crappy
movies or was it Sony whichever one had
them fox fox fox has the X-Men yeah
putting out crappy movies that did
nothing but crap on the name of the the
X-Men and at the same time you know
marel was dealing with what do we do
with them now because of the 90s we've
got 10,000 mutants in the World Y and
we're trying to refocus our efforts here
so maybe we should make some new
superheroes so they do seem to be in a
weird situation where every time a big
event comes up they're like should we
add them right not yeah like what do we
do with them because if you don't
because the and I think the problem is
honestly this is my opinion I don't
think they want them in any of the
events but the problem is if you remove
them entirely from every event that
happens then you start running into the
question of where the [__] the X-Men
you know what do the X-Men have to say
about this right it's like always say
you either read all of the Marvel
universe or X-Men by the way hi guys
hello well that's that's kind of the
problem that that I think that I don't
know what Marvel's rationale was with
the house of it would have made sense
that I think Marvel would have said
after Fox like got the rights to the
X-Men and they were like we just
basically want to like pigeon holy X-Men
that they would say House of am like
pretty much all the X-Men are gone
there's really no mutants left and so I
think their intention may have been just
kind of shuffle them to the back but I
think there was a big fan Outlast like
people were like no we really want to
see the X-Men and so I think Marvel got
to a point where they just didn't know
what to do like they tried the son of M
and that was just a total disaster what
a pile of crap yeah that was a terrible
story they tried a couple things here
and there and so they were like all
right we got to find some way to bring
them back like you had the 12 lights you
know and like the Hope like generation
hope you had all that stuff and then so
Marvel's basically like at the end of
Avengers versus X-men they're like Well
everybody's getting their powers back
and it's and it's just kind of like all
right but kind of like they didn't
really give everybody their powers back
jubilees yeah okay but nobody cares
about nobody's cared about jubilees
series went off I feel bad that Jubilee
never really like the farthest she got
was she got to lead the Gen 13 ripoff
team yeah she did I mean but there were
see there were like a lot of cool groups
though back in the 90s like you had like
Factor 3 like there were some there was
like a cool villain group like you had
really cool stuff back then but now I
think it's likee Marvel's some do what I
said yeah like maggot like yeah gotta
love that guy I actually do know quite a
bit about all that yeah right honestly I
think that if Marvel had the ability to
do it and not piss off every fan they
would separate X-Men into their own
Universe I mean that that's pretty much
half the titles of the line right now
they could that's what they're doing
with all new X-Men well I mean look at
it like original sin like nothing
happened you know like they weren't
really involved in that Infinity they
weren't really involved in that no um
they killed off the like when Professor
Xavier died and X-Men versus The
Avengers they didn't replace him on the
Illuminati they didn't put another
mutant there and they only recently put
beast on it as a like SW was the
replacement well eventually but it's
only because and even like even
storywise they tried to get rid of him
they were like oh you shouldn't be here
beast and he's like professor gave me
the gem I stay with them you know that's
true
yeah and they Beast too well they also
picked Beast like Professor X is
concerned about the mutants beast is
just a smart guy yeah yeah like they
didn't put a a real mutant the only
thing that really makes Beast a mutant
cuz he's not on any team really at this
point he doesn't do anything with him
he's just smart and he's blue that's
pretty much it an Avenger as well so
that kind of like Tes you know what okay
and I don't understand all right here's
a problem with the Avengers here's a
problem with Beast being the problem
with the AV the problems Marvel explains
got it guys he's going to explain the
problem problem all right here is
everything wrong like this is this is uh
what is it this is Comic buzfeed article
everything wrong with The Avengers yeah
this is Comic SS guys this is the cinema
version of comic books everything wrong
with The Avengers in like one minute or
less yeah like a minute exactly the
problem with the Avengers is Marvel
turned it into to a group where it's
basically like a cheerleader like it's
it's a group of cheerleaders that's it
like when you when you got beast when
you got beast and you got Spider-Man on
your team like your team probably sucks
because you have most you you have most
like all these other people I mean you
have all these people with all these
other abilities and stuff and instead
you got a guy that can climb walls and
shoot webbing out of his hands you've
got a big blue guy who's smart and can
lift some stuff like yeah yeah okay
Ben's 100% also which Avengers there's
like 15 of the other thing is you have a
thousand Avengers teams I'm not getting
a what so I'm not getting a phone call
let me close that I was like you can
like take your phone call on the
podcast you're live on the weekly right
now how you doing
this but uh but no I mean it's it's like
that that I think that's one of the big
problems Marvel ran into with the X-Men
like I think the X-Men started off as a
good idea the X-Men were like all right
now we basically like the sky is the
limit like Stanley specifically said
that the sky's the limit with the X-Men
we can do anything
with but I think that Marvel got to the
point now where it's just kind of like
the X-Men just in terms of sheer
abilities that people can have like
vastly you know outranked the Avengers
and any capability so the Avengers kind
of pale in comparison yeah so I mean
with with the Xmen you can give anybody
any ability of any kind and it doesn't
matter what it is they were just born
with it with the Avengers it was all
just abilities they somehow gained like
walked into with the exception of Beast
you know there's also the Inhumans too
yeah yeah they're they're just they're
just mutants but not mutants I mean as
from like black b i no they are not
mutants they are an ancient race made by
decree unless you're that one guy who is
the mutant inhuman that can warp
reality the Inhumans are going to be in
the TV show because they're gifted
individuals because we can't use the
term special was mirac Miracles yeah God
a complete side note and a funny a funny
thing about that I just realized this
Marvel can't use the terms mutant
because in the 1990s they fought to make
the terms mutant like a separate entity
from humans so they won that loss now
they can't use mutant yeah yeah it's
really
ironic but no seriously what what's a
really bad about like everybody with the
mutant genome just like Professor X gets
hijacked by another really smart mind
and then they all get transported to
what's a reboot of the Ultimate Universe
like it somehow cre creates itself and
they all just get there and they all
live happily ever after and they do
their own [__] Adventures right
because in the Ultimate Universe mutants
aren't the next evolution of humans they
are created in a lab based upon
Wolverine's DNA yes and I have the first
volume of that book I haven't read it
yet and you probably should it was it
was it was funny man because people were
like people were like oh my God Fox is
talking about bringing in like cable
it's going to be so awesome and people
were like they're going to use like the
ultimate version I was like do you know
what the ultimate version of cable is
and they're like no it's like it's
[__] Wolverine yeah it's just F your
Wolverine
no see Wolverine again yeah yeah and
Wolverine's son daan is not evil in that
Universe it's not even dcan it's some
dude I don't like that no the origins is
is a really the one by Bendis is really
cool um but that's but the rest of it is
I'm ashamed that I own like Frank
Miller's story The Wolverine was like
really good I swear that at the end of
Secret Wars they are going to crush the
Ultimate Universe and shut it down I
hope they're going to move the popular
characters to the mainstream universe
that's why the all new X-Men are
crossing over and we conveniently have a
mutant that can jump dimensions and take
people with her well that's just a Time
honor tradition created by lazy writers
I mean like look at House of M uh Bend
has created Lila Miller to make people
forget that or make people remember what
happed before so that we could just move
it along even though it was was it was
four issues too long anyway and then and
and then she joined she joined yeah they
create they made they did something with
her I'm like what yeah she joined up
with uh with Jamie mad's xfactor
investigation team and so like the
entire Civil War conflict she's in like
mutant town and people are like is this
the way things are supposed to be and
she's like I don't know are they and
it's like you know what just kill her
like have yeah just have like Iron Man
swoop by and just like shoot a laser in
her head and just call it a day like
Marvel is so
complicated yeah it gets it gets if you
okay here's the problem with Marvel
here's here here's the problem here's
the problem with
Marvel everything wrong with Marvel by
the problem with Marvel is they try to
interconnect way too many books into a
core storyline and they all and they
take breaks from said story lines so you
literally have to read about 10
different Marvel books on intervals to
understand what the hell is going on in
Marvel like oh I'm going to read I got
to read new Avengers now now I got to
read Avengers now you're uncy X-Men now
you got to jump over to all new X-Men oh
and by the way we're now going to do an
event that one of the writers thought
would be cool so we just put all that on
hold we're going to do AIS now and we're
going to come back to this see that's
why Marvel Knights was so cool because
Marvel could just say well here's like
these little self-contained stories done
and done and the main stuff just
continues on like that's why it was cool
it's another reason just why I like DC
it's like hey here's this universe
here's a few government organizations
here's a few
teams cool oh and then there's
also here everything right with the with
the with the Justice League and
and what what they do is they do one
event per year that will cross all the
books and it only happens for one month
that's their new philosophy it's always
one month in September they cross every
book outside of that if you want to
follow your story lines you can follow
like three Batman books you can follow
two Justice League books you can follow
like they have them literally grouped
into families and they don't go out of
that family unless it's a special event
yeah that's just what I don't like about
Batman though is that he can have
multiple [__] books and they're all
like Superman I think like in 2006 had
had six they were all Canon and that's
not even if you include all the other
like super family stuff oh yeah well no
the only the problem with the Superman
books is they allowed Grant Morrison I
believe it was Grant Morrison the writer
of Action Comics at the beginning yep
they allowed him to write his own Action
Comics and then they said okay you're
going to be the prequel to everything
else that happens in the Superman
universe and they basically said and
then great Morrison said this is a great
idea but guess what I'm gonna tell
nobody my plans yeah he lets no one in
on
his no that's Morris for every other
book is like adapting to what issue he
put out this week oh crap he met Lois
back then um we need a reccon yeah we
got a r just put it up on a
board put it Morrison is the thing
anytime that I'm ever confused when I'm
reading a DC Comic I just instantly flip
to the cover oh [__] course is gr
morson any time I've ever been confused
in DC I just flipped to the front
Morrison you know what my introduction
was to Grant
Morrison the whole Cassandra Nova
story you remember that S I do not all
right grant Morris Mor wait is that
is that no I'm thinking of magnet's wife
unless I got my facts wrong I believe
Grant Morrison is the guy who made the
whole um uh Weapon X Project convoluted
and it's the Weapon X Plus project with
like 15 weapon X's Morrison came along
and took over the
X-Men and initiated this storyline where
Cassandra Nova which it was it's so
stupid I don't remember like the basis
for cassander NOA like I think she's an
alien maybe she's not I think she's like
the dead twin sister of Xavier that kind
of like exists in his mind I don't
remember off top yeah it's it's
something weird but anyway like
Cassandra Nova launches an attack
against josha using Sentinels and wipes
out 16 million mutants yeah she killed
josha yeah yeah that was the that was a
grand Mor like and josha never recovered
like that led into the house of M like
Magneto was still in josha the entire
place has been totally obliterated yeah
but he's still there like the buildings
are all torn down it's like it's like
Eastern Europe you know and it's just
totally well and it well that was that
was actually brainchild of um what's his
name uh Joe Casada who was like he was
like there's too many mutants they even
have their own fraking country blow up
the country and then they did and they
were like no that didn't fix anything uh
it's almost
like kusada was working for William
Striker because he's like all it did was
bring them closer together what else can
we do next thing he he was like undo him
so then he pitched it to Bendis and
Bendis did House of M so like yeah it's
his like it's his call man like that was
not like Morrison being like oh you know
it be great if we just got rid of all
the mutants your Scot is so much better
than mine oh morison Scottish oh yeah I
didn't know that I just know he's
confusing oh watch him on uh the I hate
to draw anybody away from our podcast
but check out Fat Man on Batman he talks
to Kevin Smith for like a while all
right and uh they're fascinating he's I
I hate Grant Morrison's like self
convolution and the [__] but like I
love his analysis of Killing
Joke I never thought and I've reread it
I'm like oh I like Morrison as a writer
but I I just don't like how he makes he
makes things too comic Booky where he
loves it like he thinks that I know I
know he loves it and everything I hate
it well he thinks like like he thinks
comic books are like caveman paintings
that'll like inform new societies and
I'm like no well he he takes okay he
thinks comic books every era has their
and I mean you can see a lot of
documentaries on this that kind of thing
but every era has their superheroes like
we have comic books Superman Batman uh
the X-Men that's our heroes but their
every era of life has Heroes they they
look up to and are legends and myths and
Grant Morrison likes to say I mean he
does mostly with the DC guys is how he
handles it but like you know Superman
and Batman are the Gods like these are
the gods that our generation looks up to
wor them one day like yeah but I mean
like any of mors and stuff you know like
his his selfcon like uh Joe the
Barbarian is uh a solo graphic novel
that he wrote really really good stuff
it's about a kid that um has diabetes
and he's going in and out of diabetic
shock and the the entire book is just
him trying to get down the stairs to get
a soda but like he's going in and out of
of these hallucinations where like he's
the the dying child and he's like the
savior of this world and all his toys
come to life and stuff really
interesting stuff really good stuff all
of his uh Batman and Robin stuff with
Dick Grayson and Damen really good stuff
but then when you let him write make
things comic Booky that's when I don't
like him well that's what I don't like
about multiversity right now the latest
issue of multiversity the whole concept
of multi diversity is that they are in
comics being read by other superheroes
in other dimensions exactly that's
Morrison I mean it's like like Keen
Keenan Williams said he said like
Morrison is like the M Night Shyamalan
of comic books yeah I saw that my God he
is holy [__] that's sad he can set up a
great story but his endings never never
deliver it's yeah I I don't know I mean
it's Marvel is like it's taken like all
these weird twists and turns I do think
that it was like this big Pandora's Box
thing when they first did the crossover
because because here's here's what
happened like like they did mutant
Massacre and Marvel was like wow this is
this is pretty successful like let's
kind of keep it up and let's see what
happens with it they did like more stuff
and then it was like Age of Apocalypse
and they were like oh my God like we've
got to start doing more cross and it
start to turn into like huge crossover
events I mean you had all kinds of stuff
like you had like fatal attractions like
like Magneto just like rips the Animan
out of out of Wolverine's body I mean he
had like all these different things
going on and and Marvel like loved the
idea of Crossovers and crossovers were
cool but here's the problem with cross
rare that's yeah exactly when like every
three years isn't it yeah when it
becomes like a constant thing where you
always see stuff being crossed over you
lose the importance and the value of the
individual teams and the characters it's
true it's just like how I feel with
variant covers like when every issue has
like 15 variant covers they lose what
make them special in the first place
yeah they're supposed to be done in
where it has more impact and Marvel is
just one giant
crossover well Marvel literally ends
crossovers by go they were starting axis
before the original sin was over yeah
they were the original sin wasn't even
wrapped up and they're like a Marvel is
just is just one giant event one after
another like Marvel is just an event and
like that like let me have some
breathing room with the characters let
them do their own St story you know
that's one thing I do like about DC like
DC ended forever evil we haven't had a
big crossover since then yes we did have
Futures End that happened in September
but that really wasn't a crossover it
was kind of at the same time as well huh
it was kind of at the same time as
forever evil too no futes end happen
forever evil ended about May okay um and
then we had normal stories and then we
had a month break where everyone just
did a forever evil story and we're back
to their normal stories no one crossing
over right now they're implying that
there's going to be one coming up but we
have like I reading stories about the
flash I'm reading stories about Batman
I'm not reading stories about the two of
them having to fight the world ending
God of whatever yeah that's right that's
what Green Lantern's for maybe this is
something like Marvel's picking up on
maybe Marvel's like like all this C like
people hate all this crossover stuff
like I mean there there's a reason why
Marvel's coming out with axis and like
the sales are just like steadily just
going well I mean like it's funny I
remember them talking about it like
event fatigue and the guys at Marvel are
always like there's no such thing as
event fatigue if there was these books
wouldn't be selling like hot cakes and
I'm like dude cuz you're ging the only
one option yeah exactly like if I want
to know what's happening in these Comics
like I'm I have to buy them yeah right
um but eventually they will stop that's
what's happening like like comic sales
are just slowly I mean that's like
Marvel I don't know what but comic sales
are slowly just starting to to slump
back down again to a degree like it's
kind of this phase that goes in and out
based on the popularity of the movies
but of course like the comics itself are
the comics based on the movies that's
why like the war number one is a big
deal and Superior Iron Man so on and so
forth but there the stuff in between
there's the things that go on in between
these things that just aren't doing all
that well that's why like the Inhumans
have just never really been like a huge
deal since volume two they kind of were
during um during Annihilation during
Annihilation Conquest all that kind of
stuff but after that it's just kind of
like well you know it's whatever and
then like of course all this in humans
news will start coming out and you're
going to start seeing new in human
stories like all these these new things
coming out for Marvel it'll follow that
that trend but you got to look between
the popularity of the Marvel movies
versus the Marvel Comics and you got to
look at those comics and see how those
Comics are doing and that'll actually
tell you how Marvel is really doing and
things are going down like things are
are starting to slump and I'm hoping
that with this 2015 event Marvel's
seeing that Marvel's saying like Okay
people are getting tired of all these
Crossovers and stuff let's just wrap it
all up into one big universe say yeah
here's how it's all going to run get
back to the roots of having like
individual characters individual stories
and so on like Superior Iron Man is a
great step in that direction and then
from there go back to doing crossovers
periodically yeah I doubt Iron Man
number one had a She-Hulk crossover cuz
every Marvel comic has to have some
other character showing up for at least
a couple lines oh yeah which isn't which
isn't bad I mean like when you're a
superhero all your other friends are
superheroes it just kind of makes sense
that like it would so and I was okay
with that it's like oh hey there's
She-Hulk okay bye She-Hulk like
right perfect it's perfect um I agree
with you 100% but and it's funny because
secret war is only happening because
we've had so many crossovers we
literally have entire universes where
these crossovers have happened now um
and and that's why we're having a secret
Wars thing but you know I didn't even
think about it but you're 100% right
about the the fatigue or I think St said
the fatigue of these events yeah
original sin I was buying it was the one
before original sin whichever one that
was I don't remember but I was buying
all the exactly original sin I didn't
buy very many of the tians and axis guys
I'm going to say it I don't give a crap
what happens in this no I'm literally
buying the core book because this is
basically our job we have to read these
books I'm I'm not even like I'm buying
this on a a necessity for my job if this
wasn't my job I would not be buying axes
yeah yeah that's pretty much it and and
it's it's funny like because when you
when you look at Marvel like there were
some characters who are really good and
then you're just kind of like what like
like She-Hulk is a perfect example
She-Hulk number 10 just came out and
this is a great way for Marvel to like
make She-Hulk interesting again before
that like she was part of she's canell
no I thought they no I didn't think they
canceled She-Hulk did they cancel it
after number 10 it's over yeah I think
it's like I think it's either one or
that's the or that's it no way yeah you
you missed it no way yeah cuz I love she
I love she-hulk's new solo series I know
it's great but it's over is it
was which really blows cuz like I mean
like I was never really thrilled with
the art but like the book itself number
12 there you go 12 that sucks yeah but
um but no like during fear itself she
was part of like the Fearsome four she
was partnered with like Howard the Duck
and like
Frankenstein and and and it was it was
just a stupid thing yeah it was
incredbly dumb but her character is a
great character yeah you know and it's a
character that I'd love to see I'd love
to see continue in her solo series
because it's been pretty good so far but
um no I I don't I don't know I mean with
the whole Marvel thing it's it's I'm
really hoping that they look at what's
going on with the fan base of a lot of
their events and their characters and
they kind of make some changes cuz it's
getting kind of silly
yeah I don't know what else to say I I
think we've hammered this I think we've
hammered his nails into this cofin quite
a bit I mean I think I think overall the
the group here I mean Drake's kind of
not even bothering with the latest event
I think the three of us are Prett just
because I haven't gotten to the point
yet I'm still trying to catch up on all
the Marvel stuff so no and that's
understandable and it's hard to catch up
on Marvel because like DC has a bunch of
Jing off points and Marvel does have the
number ones but if you really want to
know what's going on with Marvel you
need to go back like years and start
back there
yeah and I explain this on my channel
but like I'm trying to go from uh I'm
reading from Civil War forward and then
from Miss Marvel back essentially to
because I really love Miss Marvel and
right now she isn't like she isn't
crossing over with anybody no and no
which I'm which is why I'm loving it and
so hly like if you want to read Captain
Marvel man like read the backstory on
Wikipedia and just go by the Captain
Marvel he means M Marvel the the
newv she's really good and so I'm I'm
kind of like just going in between like
I I'm learning about all the Civil War
stuff going forward and I'm kind of
working back from this that way I'm
slowly getting all the information but
it's just a long arduous process um when
I first started reading comics earlier
this year it's like okay I want to read
DC Comics new but the only reason I'm
reading DC so much because oh New 52 C I
only have 32 issues to read like
honestly that's what happened to me when
I when I was in Afghanistan for my last
appointment for getting out of military
I grabbed a bunch of Trades to catch up
with my favorite superheroes because I
hadn't read them in like five six years
you know I was like I want to catch up
on all this stuff and as soon as I got
done with a whole bunch of Trades they
were like the new V 2 we're going to
relaunch JC I'm like I guess I'll jump
on there and start buying crap I mean
that was like I'll look on Reddit like
on Reddit Marvel and somebody will post
up and they'll be like where should I
start with Marvel Comics and people will
be like start with Marvel now and I'm
like no no
you not rebooted Marvel now just started
that particular story arc that's pretty
much how it did it I was like it's issue
number one but it's not issue number one
of like the characters history ever like
like Magneto issue number one is cool
for like Magneto solo comic but if you
want to know here's the deal if you guys
want to know like the whole backstory of
Magneto go read Greg patch Magneto
Testament it's like the best four-part
Magneto story I've ever read like they
Consolidated his entire backstory and so
like they they actually made his name
Max eisenhard instead of Eric lyncher I
think they went through and like changed
all this stuff so he has like he's of
German descent instead of Polish now but
they went through like and they tied in
both like like real world historical
events in Nazi Germany and they
reconciled like every everything cuz you
had to go back and you had to read like
Uncanny X-Men numbers such and such and
you had to read like Classic X-Men which
was like a reprint of Uncanny X-Men you
had to go back and read like all these
different things because what Marvel did
with Classic X-Men back in the day is is
they would do like the beginnings or
they would reprint like a portion of The
Uncanny X-Men story but then they would
add stuff into it yeah and so you'd have
to like buy Classic X-Men if you really
want like the whole story but they went
back through and they revamped and went
through all that stuff and then actually
put it all in Magneto Testament so
really if all you want to do is learn
about the backstory of Magneto just go
read Magneto Testament and that'll tell
you everything you need to know going
into Marvel now well are they collecting
that in a trade volume right now like
because that's that's the problem is
that Marvel's not really good at
collecting past stories they're really
good at making writers tell their
stories within a trade collectible
volume yeah they're not really good at
that's what all of them are doing now
all of all of them are L like DC and
Marvel are literally every comic six
issue print like there there must to be
some kind of cheap way to print crap
that came out that I was unaware of
because they're collecting every book
you can find any superhero you want and
trade now oh yeah but they did just the
just the new stuff which is like yeah no
the the Magneto testman isn't like an
Omnibus of like all the stories or
anything like they just they went
through and like I I assume like they
read all the stories whatever and it's
like new art new storytelling like all
that stuff and it's basically like a
four-part series telling you from the
time that he was a kid up until the time
that he escaped a concentration camp now
you'd still have to go back and read
like a lot of the old like the trial of
Magneto the you know fatal attractions
the you know all those all those events
that Magneto was part of to get like in
between but the good thing now is that
you can go back and just read like the
major Magneto stories you don't have to
like spend like 10 hours looking on
Google trying to find out where his
origin story was yeah which is good such
a and then going and finding the book
and then reading the origin story now
that said uh Drake I have to suggest um
I remember who in the chat reminded me
but like Warren Ellis's moonnight
is is that the new one yeah okay I have
I have the first trade like okay that's
it stop there done because
like left I'm getting to the point with
video games like I have so many Comics
that I am I have a huge backlog that I
already own all the [__] yet I'm buying
new things like I went into the comic
store the other day it's like I needed
to research my channel and I dropped 200
bucks on on trades and then I came back
yeah which was broke the bank pretty
hard but like I got to start pretending
like I at least know something yeah on
this podcast yeah know like the the new
the waren Elis moonnight is really good
I don't know if the new people who took
over are doing it justice but I know
that at least for the for like Dean Shi
and War analysis moonnight is freaking
awesome yeah and I have it I'm more than
happy to read it totally um that's the
only one I can really recommend at this
point although if you ever were
interested in
Spider-Man the time to jump on was big
time I am not reading huge amount of
Trades between big time and now don't
read it now no I am reading Spider-Man
2099 is so good that's great all right
so guys um you know little little segue
action here yeah so speaking of big
events that are kind of going out of
control in the in the tians aren't
really making any sense to it has
anybody else been reading spiderverse
what a segue oh my God yes I am not I am
not going to read a series of comics
that feature a pig version of Spider-Man
oh no no that's the problem
I I dude I don't even know when
spiderverse has get correct me from
wrong sale it hasn't even technically
started or it just started with one
issue it f like well here's the
thing
spiderverse spiderverse the book like
spiderverse number one isn't
spider-verse spiderverse is the is in
main is in the main Amazing Spider-Man
title so spiderverse technically started
an Amazing Spider-Man number nine
although I don't came out fin which just
came out and Amazing Spider-Man number
10 comes out tomorrow I think um but
like when did it start did it start with
edge of spiderverse or all the other
pre-s spiderverse stories or is it not
like so yeah technically the annoying
part about spiderverse is it it kicked
off okay with Superior sperman 32 and I
think there was like one other one and
that made sense you know oh my God Mor
lon's a problem oh my God we're going to
have to make a team of Spider-Man I'm
like okay this is cool and then it just
stopped going in in like forward and he
just started telling random other spider
Heroes yeah well cuz otherwise how will
you know who all of these great new
pilot characters are and I say pilot
characters because edge of spiderverse
is clearly a would you read a Noir
Spider-Man book would you read a
spidergwen story would you read a
Japanese by way yes we would read a
spidergwen story and it's weird because
you know what they did was just before
this launched at the right around the
end of spectacular Spider superior
Spider-Man they closed all the spider
books yeah like that was it like we got
no more Scarlet Spider we got no more
Venom all the spider bricks were shut
down and Spider-Man for like 3 months
was running solo and now they're pushing
out all of these other books and like
okay we we're only joking we're not done
with Spider-Man but we we we need you
guys to decide what you want to read
Spider-Man like the legend spiderverse
just really doesn't interest me um
because it just seems like overly
[__] convoluted and complicated like
[__] that I don't really like um it I
picked I picked up Amazing Spider-Man 8
because it had Miss Marvel because I
like her character and I like and I I
wanted to see how they interacted cuz
she's a freaking Fang girl and it's
awesome and then I am reading Spider-Man
2099 cuz it's hilarious and wonderful
and I was like okay I'll read the other
thing where where Miss Marvel is in and
it gets [__] ConEd with spiderverse
and now I'm reading Spider-Man 2099 and
they add spider into it and it's like
well [__] you guys are ruining the books
that I enjoying because you want to tell
a goddamn Spider story and they might
die well it's not even really a Spider
story it's just they go to all the and
this is where and this I was talking
about s before the podcast the latest
issue of spiderverse which is just six
separate stories about Spider-Man is
bringing us to a whole new level of meta
because basically before this we had
different versions of Spider-Man like he
went to one universe or Spider-Man
stayed a giant spider we went to another
Universe where Spider-Man was as this
person puts it and I read that one um a
steampunk
aristocratic uh Spider Woman there's a
version of Spider-Man like that yeah
yeah um but if you and it's in the book
I'm reading here but what you do is this
book right here brought it to a whole
new Spectrum and what they're basically
implying is every version of Spider-Man
you've ever seen or heard of except for
Toby Maguire except for Toby McGuire is
is open and up for GRS and basically
like um so and a bunch of Spider-Man
you've never heard of because they never
existed want to here here's manga
Spider-Man he's involved now he is a
major he used they I remember they
launched a whole bunch of manga Marvel
Comics his was pretty cool here is the
aristocratic spiderverse
uh no one cares yep um but here's where
it gets funny and this is where it
really kind of breaks the fourth wall oh
the host pie the hostess pie Spider-Man
is what right here the guy okay in the
early when Spider-Man was last popular
he had there's a commercial like an
advertisement where Spider-Man's taking
Hostess pies to Mary Jane right in this
onepage thing [__] shows up in the
commercial Spider-Man tries to throw
Hostess pies at him and [__] kills
him yeah it's that was the mo that was
the cleverest thing I've seen in a while
was uh and then there's the the like I
was talking about earlier the comic
strip weekly Spider-Man yeah who is
literally a comic strip like um in the
newspapers like they they repeat the
same thing over and over and what's his
face more Lon even States uh what what
is with this universe they have no
short-term memory like why does he keep
asking the same questions yeah and then
he goes why does time keeps resetting in
this universe it's like things take days
or weeks to perform
yeah because that book that that strip
or newspaper strips are incredibly slow
and you have to wait like long stretches
of time because you have to dedicate one
whole panel to explaining everything
that happened in the last panel it's
dumb but uh but it was really clever
device all the there's a lot of neat
ideas a lot of neat if you will threads
going on in spiderverse uh but uh well
actually that his his pun even means
more because the concept behind
spiderverse is that one of the
Spider-Man is the Weaver and every
Spider-Man is on a thread of the
dimensions and he can pluck and move
people around yep look at s like I give
up well it is I mean like well okay see
this is why I'm not reading this see
this this story is is Rob How come every
time something's a convoluted story like
this is why I'm not reading that I I
like I like my simple stories like hey I
did my flash story line you're like this
is why I'm not reading Flash no no I
like I like simple I like simple easy to
to absorb stories like hey here's like
here's here's like okay Secret Wars
perfect example all right yeah perfect
for being perfect for being basic all
right Secret Wars molecule man molecule
man gets his powers just like tears open
a hole in the Multiverse and like the
beyonder looks through and says huh like
well that's kind of a cool like whole
thing over there so let's just see what
happens with like good and evil so then
you got good guys on one ship bad guys
on the other ship they get put onto the
planet they fight each other you've got
some stuff that happens and Dr Doom
unleashes molecule Man's powers and
Spider-Man becomes like Venom and you
got some stuff that goes on and then bam
end of the story it's it's simple yeah
no it's not simple simple it's not
simple it was 12
issues you put bonder tried to keep it
simple he tried to make it like a like a
children's action figure game where like
I put the good guys over here and the
bad guys over here but the good guys and
the bad guys immediately start fighting
with each other people start creating
factions they don't act predictably and
then those events wound up not only
disrupting their own books but they want
up bleeding into their books later and
then that spawned that awful Secret Wars
2 Series which bled into even more books
no it was exactly as complicated as it
has been
today spider- now no it's not your it is
like that's exactly what it is I think
Rob just has the nostalgic glasses on
look dude I love that book I love Secret
Wars but Secret Wars is exactly as
complicated as civil war like it's it
wasn't it wasn't deep but neither was
War everyone's like oh Civil War was
about real real light no yes it was no
it was and white it was black and white
clear as Crystal garbage and then Paul
Jenkins tries to make it somehow
elevated and winds up actually tripping
over himself with his high school level
education no it was stupid but like any
way Sal a secret Wars is is no way is is
in no way
less uh complicated or or complex
because it's not complicated I mean it's
it's basic stuff but it's nowhere near
as less complex as anything today oh it
is yes it is man no because like look at
read it again it's like we've read it we
know like it like there it's it's not
good versus evil oh sorry
Drake
what but like regardless of all that
like it is like Edge spiderverse is
overly complicated and it doesn't allow
the reader to make any conclusions
themselves because when you read um
everything that spawns this whole thing
stems from strazinsky
original take on Spider-Man which in and
of itself was trying to DEC complicate
Spider-Man um and in fact Drake if you
ever wanted to pick up Spider-Man that's
actually where I would start is jinsky
run um I can't remember what the first
volume's called but like it's not called
volume one because like for whatever
reason that' be too easy yeah oh no but
what's great is volume it it does pick
up with volume two 3 four five and six
it's just that they didn't label volume
like the first run with volume one I
don't know of course they didn't yeah no
and that way too easy yeah but like they
want new people it's like they want
newcomers to come on board what oh it's
weird they yeah but uh cinski introduces
this idea that um Spider-Man may have
gotten his powers through another means
instead of the radioactive spider or
rather that the spider like was the was
it really a radioactive spider or was it
that a spider was sent to bite Peter
Parker and it happened to get hit by
radiation and that's how Parker
rationalized it but they deliberately
put it out there so that like in such a
way that the reader could go eh like I
don't like that idea and in fact they do
it by having Peter Parker go like
mystical nonsense is not my way is not
my bag but the guy who get the Arbiter
of that information says like actually
it is and so you have these two forces
who are kind of like trying to
re-explain Spider-Man's or or and you
have two different versions and you can
pick and choose which one you want I
like that yeah and at the end of the day
uh you know who's right and who's wrong
somebody says like it's it's open
interpretation yeah somebody says it's
open to interpretation like some say
that the that the sun rises because it's
part of our solar system and blah blah
blah and some say that the sun rises
because it's meant to are either of them
wrong and it's like that's cool but then
the when they pick up these threads like
with uh the other uh later on stinski
will do a spider event not unlike spider
verse where [__] shows back up he's
this mystical vampire idiot character
and he comes back to life and he he says
unequivocably no no no it is Mystical
and and uh and and it takes away the
choice from the reader right and
spider-verse picks up on that and says
and reinforces the idea that there's
this mystical web of life and all the
spider characters are Tethered to it and
like it removes he's a kid from Queens
with spider powers
like why are we doing this like why does
it have to be that there's a spider God
and he has to like like the spider the
other ended he like dies and like
cocoons himself and like spiders turn
him into another person like it's it's
it's unbelievable oh my God you
seriously somebody play The Curtain Call
Music real
quick call music anyway
that's why spiderverse sucks like
spiderverse is not it's so out I said
this in an in a review but like it's so
outside Spider-Man's wheelhouse that
it's like alienating and and frustrating
that how about TV Little House H how
about his TV Little House bad joke so
outside of the main yeah so outside TV
little house oh no it's in there um I
I've got a question for you s you know
just he just get brought a nice little
CH what did you think of Spider-Man 2
the movie starring Toby Maguire and
particularly the train scene let's just
say it's
different I have I have a video we never
launched it um it was one we never took
it no I never I never put it up um we
did it was the episode where it was me
and S just doing the weekly poll well
what you guys don't know is when that
ended just me and S actually Drake you
were on it too and it was poised there
was literally about 45 minutes of s
ranting so hardcore about how much he
hates Spider-Man 2 to the point of
Tiffany telling him to calm down him
storming out of the room and her taking
over on the
podcast yeah I heard it was something to
behold those Sam R movies are really bad
oh all right but but here's here's the
deal like to a degree let's get back on
topic yeah like like oh we're getting
ready to get off topic even more like to
a degree I like your concept of of like
interpretation but but here's here's the
deal all right earlier like we were
talking about Civil War before we
started the
podcast all right and you were talking
about like you don't understand you know
like you were talking about like Civil
War is not not that deep of a concept I
disagree man Civil War was a deep
concept and here's here's why here's why
all right okay with Civil War it was the
debate of who's right like you have Iron
Man on the side of security you have
Captain America on the side of Freedom
now my question is this yeah people will
argue on the side of Captain America all
day long and say well he was right to go
for Freedom okay of what uses freedom to
a society that uses that freedom to
destroy itself like what's the value of
freedom to a destroyed
so like I do what they're both right I'm
going to burst your bubble right here
especially when I when I tell my entire
Civil War Story in like 5 to 10 minutes
and just Civil War is just a reason for
the superheroes to fight and if you
don't believe me yeah it's war is Secret
Wars It's Secret Wars they they always
look for a reason for the superheroes to
have to fight against each other they do
it over and over and over in Marvel
Civil War did not have a deeper meeting
as all it was was and they they they
tried to imply one but all it was is a
reason for the superheroes to fight
followed by Avengers versus X-men where
the superheroes fight
fight and Planet World War Hulk where
the heroes have to fight yeah or the
entire run of New Avengers after Civil
War where the superheroes fight each
other all the time right or or in was it
original sin where the superheroes all
discover secrets and have to fight each
other leading into now axis where the
superheroes are now all Gonna Leave No
it's I'm no I'm not going to leave I'm
not what guys you know what I'm out of
here you so all that on that we've
pissed off Rob we've pissed off S Drake
is playing Fantasy Life secretly oh okay
no no no no no no all right all right
here's no here's here's the every
time whether or not it was intended to
be something deeper or whether or not it
it wasn't but it turned out to be that
way to me like Civil War was a really
really good story because it was a
parallel to real world events like the
ongoing struggle in normal like real
world society as people say I want the
freedom to do anything that I want to
but I also don't want anybody to have
that freedom that they can impose it on
me so that's why people form laws people
don't make like Society doesn't make
laws that say you can't steal because
people think it's wrong to steal people
say make laws saying you can't steal so
nobody will steal from me like that's
why people make laws because like it'll
disrupt Society like you can't like
there you can most laws in fact all laws
are put in place so that like the fabric
of society doesn't unravel like you
can't steal because it will destroy our
economy like you can't kill because
people would murder each other and it
would like [__] up a road system because
like there'd be all these cars full of
corpses
like the problem the problem right here
Rob with with Civil War honestly what it
comes down to
[Music]
ising the problem with Civil War and the
problem with pretty much all the Marvel
events is perception what it's going to
come down to is someone who's a super
fan and really wants to look into all
and read every single time for civil war
and wants to look for a deeper meaning
is going to go Civil War has a deeper
meaning it's all about privacy and it's
all about rights and it's all about that
kind of a thing and someone who's just
looking at the cover art is going to go
it's about superheroes fighting that's
what it's about and but it doesn't even
just apply to Civil War it applies to
everything it depends on how much you
want to take what they're giving you
okay I can look at um the stories of
Superman fighting against dark side and
singing Dark Side the death as a whole
new take on gods and mythology that
Grant Morrison's going or you can look
at it as Superman just saying Dark Side
to death that's the stupidest thing I've
ever heard in my
life appes to movies it applies to
everything I mean some people look at
the Matrix as this could legitimately be
like are we all trapped in our own
brains in a virtual reality world and
people like me look at it goes that was
a kickass action movie exactly sucks
well no but but I mean okay if all you
did was read like The Standalone Civil
War Stories yes that's the attitude that
you would take you would say it was
Marvel writing a story about heroes
fighting Heroes
if if you read if you read Civil War
Frontline oh yeah yeah and you focus on
like Ben urick and Sally Floyd like
there's a much bigger concept going on
there yes but they had to invent that
concept like that was Paul Jenkinson's
idea that wasn't part of the story like
that was and that's also a tie yeah and
for the record Civil War itself doesn't
even stick doesn't even fit its own
continuity because no one was on the
same page there's holes in Civil War if
you read it all oh yeah there are there
are holes in Civil War
but in the end of the day Rob in the end
of the day it's a comic book in Civil
War even if you want to look even even
hold on hold on hold on hold on I I know
I interrupt all the time but let me get
this one out let me get this one
out it's just a comic book and the fact
of the matter is regardless of what you
want to think it says and what's going
on it's literally about Iron Man versus
Captain America yeah that's that's what
it boils to I agree man like I I made 22
videos explaining Civil War I understand
the concept of Civil War I know what
it's about and and I get I mean at the
end of the day like we separate
ourselves and and and we read comic
books we make videos about them for a
living that's what we do but the fact
remains that at the end of the day like
i' like to look for for like really cool
Concepts and stories like it's just kind
of a personal thing it's one of the
things that I like to look at like for
me I do the same thing I love it too I
love do my God man Are You Gonna Let Me
Talk No No's like I don't know why mommy
and daddy fighting no you probably
should cut me off cuz I will keep going
like I will I will I wase I'm like yes
you're right there is deeper meanings
and a lot of stories do and Grant
Morrison is like the Pinnacle of every
story I write will have a deeper
meaning and now it just came full
circle you're right but the problem is
even if there is a super deep meaning
this is not the medium to get that point
across yeah you're you're you're
different people who just wants to see
people fight and while there are fans
like us who read every single book and
want you know and I want I want axis to
have a purpose and I want it to tie into
things and I want to know why is Reed
Richards being a [__] and why is the
Justice League cutting off a guy's arm
and at what point do we accept Superman
as an alien and how can Batman be the
smartest guy in the entire universe and
why why is Tony Stark so intelligent
that he can invent a machine that will
destroy a world but he can't put two and
two together that maybe this man should
not drink like there are so many deeper
meanings that I want I want to know
about in the comic books at the end of
the day we won't get the ones we want
because they're comics
right well well because they're run by
other people who have their own thing
like their agendas and editorial control
unfortunately really influen the
story I understand that and I get that
Marvel com Marvel is a business Marvel
makes Comics to sell money hey interrupt
it because my superhero Alter Ego is the
interruptor the interrup I agree with
that I agree with that I become the
interruptor it only happens for about an
hour and a half once every week but I
become the interruptor um
no I I I get that if Marvel could sit
down and Marvel said hey guys let's like
there's all these political themes like
all this hot stuff going on in like the
real world like let's make a story that
kind of reflects that and let's and then
it just blows up I get them that's a
marketing decision Marvel made Civil War
because a lot of people bought it it was
probably the bestselling comic book
series in since like the year 2000 maybe
even a little bit before then and so it
it was a it was a huge deal when it came
out and so I get that it was all
business Civil War pulled Marvel out of
irrelevancy yeah I Civil War saved
Marvel like unequivocably I have no
doubt about that it's just I don't think
it's the second coming and I agree with
you and what what Marvel learned from
Civil War was not how to tell a story
about civil rights and PR privacy and
you know all this the future age and
learning all that crap what they learned
is that if they stay super topical on
something it will sell books BuzzFeed
learned the same thing and now they're a
multi-billion dollar top 10 list
organization
yeah um does anyone have any closing
remarks cuz we are running out our hour
and a half time we are so I I am going
to I'm going to because we could
probably do this argument all day we
could do this dance all day because
every story has a deeper meaning to the
people who read it that's that's where I
want to leave this is regardless of it
being a comic book or not you know the
story of Cara zorl coming down and
becoming Red Lantern is all about Teen
Angst and how teens can go fight against
it or it could just be her a reason for
her to punch the the Red Lantern yeah I
mean you don't know and everybody can
take a comic book for face value or look
for a deeper meaning that doesn't exist
and then decide that that's there you
know what I mean you don't know exist
well and one step further like uh why is
the door blue in in this comic in this
book like is it because the the the
writer of the novel wanted to show the
character's inner depression or is the
door just [__] blue it's up to
interpretation everything is up to
interpretation I like how you guys I
like how you guys are like you instead
of being like Rob I think it's cool that
that like that like you're a lover of
philosophy and you like getting into
these these concept instead you guys are
like well if you're like Rob and you're
looking for [__] that's not there you
know no I'm I'm not you're you're trying
to understand why the door is blue when
in reality the door was just made blue
because the artist just decided to use
that color you know I mean but it's it's
just everything in the world is just
open to interpretation because everybody
everybody is a unique individual that
has a different life they see different
things and they take mean different
meanings out of anything some people
think that you know that their life is
all fate and some people believe that
it's just God's plan or whatever but at
the end of the day it's everything in
the world is what you make of it yeah
right and and that's a great Point Rob
and I'll end it with that you might see
the different meaning of Civil War no
hold on hold on and it may be there it
may be there I don't see it I see
superheroes punching each other but in
the exact same flipped reversal I can
read deeper into my DC books than you
can and you just see Superman [__] is
God you know like yeah and like singing
to Dark Side that's what I mean so we
can both play the exact same game for
the stories that we love and on that
point guys let us know in the comments
down below if there's any stories that
you feel there's deeper meanings to so
that s can pick them apart because s is
the guy that's going to do that s will
be I love comics and I apologize for
anyone that I offend with my very
verbose opinion it's not a uh it's okay
I love you thank you maybe we should
have a second a second podcast every
week which is just 30 minutes of us
looking for the deeper meeting in a
story I I check this out check this out
so the beyonder is like he kind of like
represents like the amalgamation of like
he's all religion non understanding of
the world and like good and evil and
stuff and so like he just does dumb
stuff and he and he looks like John
Travolta from Saturday night did you
watch that video that I sent you yeah
that was weird I thought it was awesome
I thought it let's close out and then we
can Yammer about the video you sent over
okay so guys thank you as usual for
joining us in the weekly poll as usual
uh we'll be here every week um we're now
moving the time to Tuesdays at 6:00 p.m.
Eastern that is the planned permanent
time for the show we'll be here every
week um I do want to State real quick we
are launching it is not launched so if
you go look at it right now it is
literally just a standalone thing but we
are launching www.the weekly pool.net
or. ninja whichever you want to go to um
the purpose of this website will be a
resource for you to get your comic book
news a funnel like aggregation point so
you can see all of the YouTube Avengers
and and all of our videos and how we
come together you can get the podcast
there weekly right now is just funneling
our videos but the as of January 1st it
will launch officially with forums and a
community and a great place for you guys
to go and if this is something you guys
might be interested in being a part of
being a writer for it or maybe a forum
moderator send your emails to myself um
comicstorian gmail.com um and I'll
forward them to the appropriate people
because right now I cannot remember
either one of their emails off the top
of my head Rob at Marvel explain. okay
and I'm s at tous.com I've got nothing
to do with
this.com so it's Rob at Marvel explain.
salot tous.com send it to all three of
us if you can but if you send it to one
of us we will make sure it gets to the
right person this is a giant project we
are all working towards and I mean we're
excited about it and we hope you guys
get excited about it too now on our
usual closing remarks um Rob what is
going on on Marvel explain for the week
oh god um more age road to Age of
Apocalypse stuff God people don't
understand how massive this is going to
be a lot of people don't get it like why
are you explaining Excalibur like are
you serious like come on like this is
all going to go towards Age of
Apocalypse so New Mutants will be out
tomorrow um and after that I'll work on
whichever one I had lined up after I
think it's Generation X so basically I'm
going to explain Jubilee leading a group
that nobody cared
about but uh yeah that's just a series
of videos coming up for the road to Age
of Apocalypse pretty much it awesome all
right Salon what's going on on every day
of TV little house because every time I
look at your channel there's something
new it's true uh probably in the next
couple of hours I'll launch our review
of the new Batman number 36 on off the
rack back um we're having a uh the new
back issues comes out on Thursdays
wherein we discussed the James Cameron
Spider-Man script and uh I think next
week for back issues we're gon to do
fear itself oh God great story yeah
that's it's a I like to call it the
Forgotten Marvel event because nobody
nobody remembers
that it's got steart on Art so it's
really good people are like House of M
and they're like Civil War and they're
like dark rain and Siege yeah secret
invasion Siege and then uh whatever yeah
and then whatever happened there no yeah
just this huge like one year long Gap y
but Marvel what if people don't know is
Marvel actually shut down for that year
and decided to test the waters of no
Comics somebody just snuck in and
released sphere
itself um so Drake what's going on over
at Comic Drake for the week what do you
got plan well uh nothing is really
happening as of right now because uh I'm
getting some new Lighting in the mail
tomorrow I got uh some some awesome
stuff um but the comic Dr channel has
officially launched I am producing
regular videos I tried out a new show uh
this past week which is a first issue
Impressions where I talked about
Superior Iron Man uh Captain Falcon
Mighty Avengers and Lady Thor but uh I
finally got the set in order and it is
this uh really Swanky throne with the uh
with the comics all there so hopefully
with the lighting it won't look like
absolute [__] on camera but uh
video
that well Betty what's coming on comic
story thank you Dr for asking you
know um I'm actually I'm trying this
week I'm trying my best and I picked a
really bad week to try and do it cuz now
that I'm feel finally feeling better
familyes out of the Town um like five
video games come out and I'm like this
is the week I'm going to get back on
schedule and do things properly and by
the way I got five video games to
play u but no I just put out on the next
part of the flash story line which is
actually issues 6 through 17 of the new
P2 lunch um and it's like three story
lines that inter WP over and over they
tble up on themselves and coming to an
end um I'm coming out with uh the the
most important Green Lanterns video this
week I'm coming out with a video that
explains all the reverse flashes all the
versions of him and uh this is the one
which is why we I brought the incursions
today later this week I'm aiming for
Thursday is going to be the new Avengers
1 through 24 book nice which is all the
beginnings of the incursions and the
start of this whole thing and it'll be
the first video that I make which is
pretty much going to be left on a super
Cliffhanger Marvel explain style because
I can't end it because it's still
technically hold on wait hold on wait a
minute left on a super Cliffhanger well
no cuz you do the individual issues so
you have the normal issue Cliffhangers I
normally wrap the stories up I'm saying
so normally my stories are complete but
this is going to be like the complete
story question mark you know could there
be consequences Bennie I don't know
could there could there b could there be
consequences one stupid Cliffhanger joke
and you're like I even put River flash
in the
image I thought that was hilarious I
decid I was like could there Benny could
there could there but uh anyway so but
no you wantan to give want to give our
closing any kind of closing remarks Rob
uh I think we're good for technically
your
show I mean I think we're good for the
most part guys um yeah again if you guys
are are if you guys are interested send
us emails um there's no real standard on
on like what your writing history is I
mean just keep in mind guys just because
you send us an email with a a writing
prompt doesn't mean that we're going to
post it on the website um we're going
through we're looking at them we're
analyzing them to make sure that that
they have the content that we're looking
for that they're up to par but don't say
well because you haven't really written
anything for you know any articles or
anything that you shouldn't do it like
send us something the worst we can do is
just say that that you know worst we can
do is correct it send it back to you
worst we can do is say right about this
instead I mean it's the worst we can do
is say no I mean it's you know it's
we're not I mean s what are you really
looking for in the the right because
honestly guys you sent him into to us
s's the guy because he's he's pretty
much an English teacher I think he is
maybe maybe not I don't know kind
of scre behind you there's a cat sitting
on the back of your chair right now yeah
he like he's very friendly um uh as far
as Ryder goes the the things we're
looking for I don't want full articles
just yet because we won't be able to
launch for a while uh but what I'm
taking right now I'd like to see maybe a
link to something you've written before
just to get an idea of what your Pros is
like and the things I'm really accepting
are some pitches I'd like three kind of
like I hate to use the term but like
buzz feedy kind of pitches like what
something that like would would last
would like has staying power and then
one topical pitch that you have that
might either come out in the next month
or two all right give him an example
like like what what kind of you know
like I would not want to use like 26
reasons why like we're why why being an
Avenger would it sucks or you know um
you're you know why a mystical
Spider-Man is a better Spider-Man uh you
know just just different kind of
articles that are about comics in
general or specifically but like enough
to be to reach audiences you know um
we're really kind of trying it all and
seeing what kind of fits the best for us
so but I'd like for it to be more news
oriented as well so hopefully that'll
come but like I would hate to have like
a bunch of articles about how Thor 2 is
really cool and then have the l site
launch like in three months and be like
that was topical I guess like you I
don't waste people's time yeah so okay
good enough and uh and Drake how's
Fantasy Life uh really good I am a
blacksmith Carpenter Taylor mercenary
Paladin cook and a few other classes at
the same time so on on on a on a
10-second review would you say Fantasy
Life is a great game for anyone with
ADD yes it's Animal Crossing but with
RPG elements there you go okay so anyway
all right guys thank you as usual this
is the end of the show 1 hour 30 minutes
in um make sure you check back here next
Tuesday same time um we'll all be here
hopefully and uh I mean next next week
we're going to do a 10p person podcast
we're going to find six more people bad
time same bad Channel anyway uh we will
catch you guys later all right bye have
a good one guys